hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday April 20 2020 how's it go are you
hanging in there you're running out of
[ __ ] projects to do oh my god this
has been the longest month of my [ __ ]
life Jesus Christ
remember when you watched the Shawshank
Redemption how that movie was so long I
was like what the [ __ ] is going on then
I realized oh I know what they're doing
they given me the sense of what it's
like to do time I'm not [ __ ] on the
movie either cuz I love the movie but it
was [ __ ] long the guy was in jail for
a long time right
hey I don't know anyway um Jesus Christ
if you guys ever wanted to know what it
was like to be a comedian out on the
road and you had to kill a day waiting
for your show later on that night you
know this is what it feels like remember
that back in the day you just be sitting
there going oh hey you know I heard they
got an exhibit downtown they first
Ferris wheel ever was made it's like a
20 minute walk if you want to do that
the worst is when I get paired up with a
comic who didn't want to go and do
anything we just would sit in the
[ __ ] condo you know ordering food
plays brought his PlayStation I remember
whenever I saw the comics that brought
his PlayStation I was always like
alright that guy's not gonna make it
like I was working harder because I was
going to go to the [ __ ] arch in st.
Louis by the way one of the scariest
tourist attractions I've ever been to a
lot of people probably don't know this
but you can actually go up into the arch
and it's like these egg I don't they
still like that they look like little
eggs these elevator thing that brings
you up it's like the thing that [ __ ]
more queues to get out of on Mork and
Mindy now there's a 40-year old [ __ ]
reference right
so you go up this [ __ ] thing
and you start thinking like well wait a
minute at some point am I gonna start am
I gonna be like laying on my back as I
start going up the arch and obviously
you know they what they do is is there's
like a seer almost like a series of
locks our boat goes through like a what
do they call one of those [ __ ] things
canal you know like the Panama Canal
series the locks thing close behind you
fill it up with water rise them up that
[ __ ] they kind of do the elevator
version of that but as you're waiting
like the [ __ ] thing is swinging and I
swear to god it looks like a plastic
piece of [ __ ] then you get up to the top
and the only way to look out is you lay
down on your stomach and look out these
little windows and because of how high
it is and how skinny it is it has to
give a little bit when the wind blows so
it won't [ __ ] tip over so you're up
there laying on your stomach looking out
this little window and you're feeling
this thing [ __ ] moving every is up
there like whoa whoa then you get up
there and there's really nothing to look
at I remember there was the baseball
stadium you looked at that and then
you're like wow look at this beautiful
downtown area that nobody's in cheap
Hill why did you have to [ __ ] on the
Midwest I don't know anyway yeah I am I
am like I'm out of ideas and I've just
been staying like at this point like I
remember I was kind of being like
alright every two three days I'm gonna
go for a drive and that's become now
like once a week and I remember it used
to feel weird that I never left my house
for a day and now it's starting to feel
normal and I was just my head I thought
today was like is this what it's like to
be on welfare you know I know it isn't I
know it isn't I know you live in a way
shitty or [ __ ] whatever but like I
would love to interview somebody on
welfare and just be like how long is
does a year feel like compared to when
you had a job
I guess you have a shitty job but just
drag I think anytime you're just doing
something you don't want to be doing
like if you're on welfare and you're
loving it
I bet the years fly by I don't have no
[ __ ] idea what I'm talking about go
[ __ ] yourself so you feel you'll fill up
a [ __ ] hour when there's nothing
going on by the way I am not even
entertaining any of these conspiracy
theories that this is a [ __ ] move
China made to try and take over the
[ __ ] world
Jesus Christ the the randomness of
letting of virus loose that that's not
going to come back and attack your own
people and let me guess they already
have a vaccine that they gave to their
billion of [ __ ] people
um I don't underneath enlike somebody
sent me all you know what I'll just just
for the entertainment value I will click
on this this this [ __ ] new world
order here thing that Yanis papas from
history hyena oh this is this is him
doing mr. Papas Chinese plot for world
domination all right I love mr. mister
Panos sorry mr. Pappas mr. Panos
one of the many brilliant [ __ ]
characters that he does how that guy
isn't on SNL I just yeah I I don't I
don't even understand I don't even
understand
Yanis papas everybody Italian guy anyway
I I just I don't I don't know what the
[ __ ] to do now with myself
I'm just hoping because it's getting
hotter out here we had a little heat
wave that it's just gonna burn this
thing out and there's all these weird
things going on now where states are
starting to act independently in like I
think like Oh in Omaha Nebraska they're
gonna open a comedy club which i think
is great but then like I was kind of
reading this email about the whole
situation and it just kind of seems like
they're just letting the comedy club
decide how to disinfect
my buddy was telling me there was some
other [ __ ] state they're opening up
but one of the things that are opening
up is a bowling alley is it just gonna
be for the [ __ ] guys who bring their
own bowling balls cuz my buddy was going
they don't everybody sticking their
fingers in the same goddamn balls I mean
that's his hobby so [ __ ] daddy I
don't know I think we're gonna be fine
and IIIi believe it's all gonna open now
I'm gonna say this right now I'm gonna
go out on a limb here
I'm gonna go esp in here and make a
prediction and I'm gonna say that
they're gonna open it back up on May
15th they they have to they have to one
of the best [ __ ] rants I've seen
about all of this I just don't want to
say his last name wrong is it Vic deep
at eddo is that how you say I don't know
I'm gonna know I'm gonna butcher it I'm
[ __ ] Irish we have short last names
we don't have all these wonderful vowels
and all this like the Italians do his
[ __ ] rant about the banks and all of
that is where I wish all Americans heads
were at they're sitting there talking
about Trump and Clinton and Obama and
Bush and all of that
it's nothing is clearer to me right now
then even the government works for the
[ __ ] banks everybody is losing money
everybody is losing money but not the
banks not the [ __ ] bank stay they'll
give you three months off and then on
the fourth month you owe the back three
plus the points like how the [ __ ] am I
even worked for [ __ ] 90 days why
can't they just treat the economy like a
video game and just hit pause and when
this [ __ ] thing's over
whatever your april mortgage will then
say it's over the beginning of august
and you just play April's in August and
that's it just like pictures broke it
down it totally made sense just add
three months to the end of the mortgage
and that's it now
no no banks will not do that they will
not do that complete everybody else
making sacrifices everybody else trying
to do whatever these [ __ ] doctors and
nurses you know who a [ __ ] working 90
goddamn hours a week help
people out everybody's making [ __ ]
sacrifices the banks foggy oh alright
but you go on the internet and what are
people talking about you're talking
about the guns the government trying to
control you
Trump's a [ __ ] idiot but Bubba and
all that type of [ __ ] it's just like
it's the banks you're yelling at the ass
or the problem although I got to be
honest with you after after you know
Trump said you know to inject household
cleaner maybe into your body maybe
that'll help
that's my I want people who are Trump
supporters to write in and defend why
you still think that guy is presidential
material why you can sit there and be
and don't even hit me with that well you
know he's got a lot he's got a lot of
people surrounding him to help him out
just imagine if you ran a deli okay and
you were interviewing somebody to make
bacon egg and cheese sandwiches and they
knew how to make a bacon egg and cheese
sandwich but in the job interview when
they taught in the u.s. to avoid if for
whatever reason you asked him about a
solution to the kovat 19 problem and
they suggested that you inject household
cleaner into yourself would you hire
that person would you let that person
touch the food with or without gloves
I'm asking you because that's what
fascinates me about human behavior I
don't know in the last I don't know how
many years since it all became social
media is how the sports fan mentality
has entered like politics where you know
my team's clean your team's dirty you
know bah bah bah bah bah and all that
say oh speaking of that [ __ ] you guys
watch the [ __ ] Jordan documentary oh
my god out of all the teams that I
[ __ ] hated in my life the [ __ ] bad
boys and Detroit Pistons were at the top
of the list and last night my hatred
went even higher I'm actually not even
hating them now and I'm just like
fascinated with Isaiah Thomas
because they they was showing the whole
thing we're like you know I remember
like they used to beat the [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of Jordan he came in the paint they
would just [ __ ] knock him on his ass
take him on it take out his legs drop
him on his [ __ ] head throw elbows to
his throat every [ __ ] thing you could
do and he lost like two years in a row
and as much as it killed him he walked
up and still shook their hands and said
good luck in the next round right and
then when the Bulls finally beat the
Pistons they walked off the court and
didn't shake [ __ ] hands and they got
a ton of [ __ ] saying the bad boys were
actually a bunch of [ __ ] and bla bla
bla bla bla right so it's a 30 year old
story right so anyway they have Isaiah
on the documentary it's 30 [ __ ] years
later and he has an opportunity to sit
there and be like yeah man we shouldn't
have done that we shouldn't have done
that man we should have shook their
hands you know we played him real tough
you know we did a lot of borderline [ __ ]
and this kid went and he [ __ ] worked
out in the offseason and he and he
learned the triangle offense he was open
to it he started kicking it out to John
Paxson and and they beat us fair and
[ __ ] square he shook our hands when
we beat him so it's only fair that we
shake his hand he had the opportunity to
just say that and what does he do what
he throws the Celtics under the bus and
that is all you need to know about that
man that's all you need to know [ __ ]
hilarious and then they cut to the clip
of the Celtics not shaken the Pistons
hands and what's hilarious in the clip
is you see Isaiah running over to
[ __ ] Kevin McHale to shake his hands
it's like Isaiah I thought you just said
you didn't do that why are you running
over to shake Kevin McHale's oh because
you
oh oh that's right we don't shake hands
but when you beat Jordan in the Bulls
you had no problem shaking his hand oh
if you win you shake hands but if you
lose get the [ __ ] out it was [ __ ] it
let me I don't know I think it says a
lot when the guy he was left off the
dream team okay and you know Bird and
Magic had a vote and they did not cast
it they like yeah [ __ ] this guy [ __ ]
that guy so anyway whatever it was I got
a big heated debate with with Yanis
Pappas who tried to say the Celtics were
dirty too because of the Kurt Rambis so
he took one [ __ ] play in a 10-year
period I go name another one that really
sticks out all right I'm not saying we
didn't play I would say the Celtics were
somewhere between the Showtime Lakers in
the early 90s Knicks obviously leaning
way more towards the early nineteen Ickx
but I didn't think the early 90s Knicks
were dirty
I don't think playing okay these guys
are faster than us we got to play more
physical that exists in every level of
the game my thing is when somebody
leaves their feet and you have no regard
for their safety which is what the
Celtics did to Kurt Rambis that was a
dirty play okay but every [ __ ] team
has that play you can you can pick it
out where yeah they should have done
that that was a dirty play people lose
their composure bah bah bah bah bah
whatever dad all [ __ ] exists but I
will tell you this I've been out here
for [ __ ] 13 years and I've talked to
all the old-school hardcore Laker fans I
mean I the zillions of them and all we
talk about is how great those games were
all right and all we talk about is then
when Jordan came along and bla bla bla
bla bla and that [ __ ] get those games
against the Celtics where he scored 49
and then he scored 63 still lost but
like and everybody just skips past the
[ __ ] Pistons cuz no one respects it
the way they played they took it they
just took it too far that's it and I'm
not even saying all of them because I
still Eve
now cuz I go back now right now look at
how much I hated the [ __ ] 76ers
I [ __ ] love those guys now I love
going on the internet and watching them
[ __ ] Andrew Tony like I was actually
one night looking up Andrew Tony like a
jersey this is me as a Celtics fan I
[ __ ] hated them in the early sit but
the end of the day I respected him I
remember John dr. Jay and Larry Bird
literally had a fistfight in a game and
the next time they played they shook
hands because they respected each other
as much as the Celtics and Lakers hated
each other
Bird magics rivalry they became friends
alright then you look at the dream team
they're all together who don't they let
on the team Isiah Thomas alright I'll
let you do the [ __ ] math I'll let you
do the [ __ ] man I couldn't [ __ ]
believe that the Celtics didn't shake
our hands it's like Isiah magic I mean I
mean Jordan shook your hand after all
you did to him back-to-back [ __ ]
years this isn't about the Celtics
stupid jesus [ __ ] christ by the way
why would why would any team shake your
[ __ ] hand I can't believe that Jordan
would even shake in the [ __ ] that
minds we did back in the day when they
shook hands with Claude Lemieux I just
this is the thing when it comes to this
[ __ ] okay cuz I'm not gonna sit here and
act like you know in the history of
Boston sports we've had no dirty players
I'm never gonna suggest it cuz every
everytime does I [ __ ] hate dirty
players I hate dirty play and especially
when you [ __ ] do something that could
possibly end somebody's [ __ ] career
consistently okay everybody you know can
lose their composure alright and have a
moment where you did something that you
shouldn't have done like I don't think
dr. J should have been throwing [ __ ]
jabs while another guy and his team is
holding Larry's arms but at the end of
the day it was one incident overall dr.
J was an ambassador to the game total
[ __ ] class
alright that current rambha's play
filthy [ __ ] play hard foul whatever
you want to call it was [ __ ] filthy
absolutely [ __ ] filthy no regard for
that guys Kurt Rambis is safety
absolutely I would never say that that
wasn't a dirty play
however you know McHale didn't do that
there's not like he has that one [ __ ]
highlight there isn't like you know a
12-year period where this guy was
considered the dirtiest guy in the
league that [ __ ] dude on Golden State
Warriors how many I'm in 40 years of
watching basketball I never saw a guy
take a jump shot and accidentally kick
somebody in the balls three times that
that happened oh you wait till somebody
jumps up to take a shot and then you
stick his youth foot underneath so then
when they land they roll their ankle
like those types of guys I felt I think
they shouldn't be in the league
headhunters and all of those types of
things so just so you don't think that
you know because I definitely being a
Celtics fan I am NOT without prejudice
here but I'm just judging how all of
those teams and viewed them and how
Isaiah was left off of the [ __ ] dream
team you know I think it kind of speaks
for itself when everybody sort of
straight across the board kind of felt
the same [ __ ] way but having said that
though I loved John Salley I loved Joe
Dumars Vinny the microwave Johnson I
liked him and I even think that like
Rick Mahorn was more towards Charles
Oakley than a Bill Laimbeer Bill
Laimbeer was just a sociopath like he
and it's funny now when you watch him
talk about those games how he views them
he's like you know we tried to play a
mind game that's my favorite quote ever
we tried to play a mind game like like
they were playing chess it's like Bill
you were kind of waiting till somebody
was vulnerable and then just taking
their legs out I mean that's not really
a mind game the other guy's sitting
there going like hey man is it me or is
like what the [ __ ] you like you you you
you're [ __ ] with
head I mean I guess you were [ __ ]
with that head in that you weren't
dropping them on their head so I don't
know and I always think it's bad for the
sport when a team like that wins I mean
a the 74 74 Flyers almost ruined the
league as far as their works I shouldn't
say far I mean they were still selling
tickets obviously but as far as their
ability to grow the way the NBA was
growing the way the NFL grew MLB was
already the pastime the way the NFL and
NBA were able to grow and catch up and
pass the national pastime hockey was
held back by you know the slapshot era
and when they went back-to-back and
there was nothing done about it
yeah it just created this really bad era
although I would say by the 80s though
there was there was the perfect balance
but you know I'm not listening I'm not
progressing anybody's there
Championships or whatever but like I
don't know I oh I hope that made sense
it didn't come off just as some Celtic
fans sour grapes because I love Joe
Dumars defense and I loved watching John
Salley run the floor I mean I really
respected there was a lot but there was
just like you know you know what I'm
saying this is it's like what it takes
to make the NBA you know specifically
the NBA with this did their draft
there's so few spots you know the
[ __ ] NFL it's like a three-day thing
the NBA I mean I think it's over in
about like 90 minutes there's like three
rounds or something ridiculously short
and there's so few spots and I would
just think every [ __ ] year if you're
in the NBA and you're one of those
middle-of-the-pack guys and you have to
figure out how to [ __ ] survive every
[ __ ] year as another group of
number-one draft picks knowing full well
that anybody picked in the first round
is going to get playing time and knowing
full well that the future hall-of-famers
each year coming to the league and
you're sitting there starting to get
forced out what you have to do how hard
it is to stay in a league where there's
only what is there eleven twelve spots
on each team so to have a team out there
that doesn't give a [ __ ] about your
career and his in his playing past
aggressive into the area of like this
this hit could end your [ __ ] career
and admittedly like I said you know that
Rambis won that was a possible career
ender had he landed on his [ __ ] head
everybody has examples of that but when
you build your whole game around that I
think that that's what I even like Chuck
Chuck Daly
I love the suits all of that type of
[ __ ] there was a lot of stuff that I
liked I loved the city of Detroit I just
don't respect that [ __ ] style up like
there that's what a stand-up comedian
thinks about professional basketball if
I'm reading my [ __ ] buddy who [ __ ]
made me lose my [ __ ] mind today when
I was talking about this [ __ ] now Jesus
Christ yeah this [ __ ] guy drives me
up the wall I sweated I can't even I
can't [ __ ] read that anyway so let me
just your isn't a sports argument when I
try to do so people can hear me as I
admit to the faults on my own [ __ ]
team so maybe you'll be a little
open-minded cuz and I just walked out
said oh this team's a bunch of piece of
[ __ ] and [ __ ] them they're not real
champions but my team is without sin I
try not to do that that's tough to do
with certain sports fans so anyway so
here we are people where we're in day
9640 eight of this [ __ ] I'm predicting
may 15th they're going to open it up and
there's gonna be a lot of propaganda
that it's gone but what they're really
gonna do is just be like ah you know
what whoever gets it gets it at this
point and you know hopefully the testing
will
somehow trickle down to small towns like
Los Angeles remember we can test people
if you're starting to feel a little
weird I don't know I think they should
reopen the economy not because it's safe
just simply because I'm bored I've run
out of [ __ ] to do I played good times
bad times at 82 BPM yesterday 13 BPMS
away I'm not gonna lie to you I'm having
the [ __ ] time of my life with that
[ __ ] I'm having the time of my life
hanging out with my daughter and I've
been lying to myself throughout this
that I don't miss stand-up I don't think
I did for the first couple of weeks but
now I'm feeling backed up and I didn't
realize what a release it was to [ __ ]
do stand-up and just get up there and be
like this is what I think I'm yelling it
into a mic and you have to listen cuz
I'm louder than you I didn't understand
the privilege of that I always knew it
was a privilege to do it but now last
night actually went for a drive and I
got as far as the Laugh Factory and that
was too sad to see that and I couldn't
drive all the way down to the store and
I just made a left and headed back down
south again just [ __ ] do it
Jesus Christ I mean what do you do this
would be a great time if you had rosetta
stone to just finally learn another
language you know if you don't have a
bunch of kids driving you up the [ __ ]
wall anyway man I was a lunatic this
morning my wife's [ __ ] pissed at me
and it always takes me 20 minutes after
the fight for the first 19 minutes I've
never felt more right in my life and
then in the 20 minutes that thought
comes in yeah you know maybe you were
and then by 21 minutes I'm like all
right I'm an [ __ ]
you know what are you gonna do I mean
that's but it even if you're not the
[ __ ] that is the way to solve the
argument with your wife that's you you
do just apologize anyway alright what
the [ __ ] do I talk about now do I do
read a little advertising let's read a
little advertising shall we everybody we
all shop online a lot but did you know
you can make online shopping even better
you can with honey honey is the free
online shipping tool that saves you
money online honey automatically finds
the best promo codes and applies them to
your cat which makes online shopping
finally feel as easy as it's supposed to
be how it works
imagine you're shopping on one of your
favorite sites Target Best Buy Sephora
Macy's eBay Etsy Walmart etc there's a
lot of examples when you check out this
little box drops down and all you have
to do is click apply coupons wait a few
seconds for it to scan for every promo
code on the internet watch the prices
drop honey is found it's over 18 million
members over two billion dollars in
savings not using honey is literally
passing up free money it's free to use
and installs in just a few seconds plus
it's backed by PayPal so you know it's
good get honey for free at join honey
calm / / that's join honey calm / / oh I
almost forgot oh I can't make the
announcement now because in case people
blow through this I got news he's a tea
I got news on that that movie I did last
year the king of Staten Island starring
Pete Davidson Marisa Tomei a film by
Judd Apatow I have I have I got
information on all that all that stuff
there when it's coming out all right
hymns what a what what's a common issue
men's face but don't want to talk about
you gonna talk about their peepees the
size of their dick their dick not going
up
their pubes not being silky-smooth
something about the dick it's always the
dick right that's what it always comes
down to if that's what people think that
guy's just walk around talking about
their dicks all the time they don't but
you know if there's something wrong with
your dick you don't want to bring it up
I'll give you that how about that what's
the common issue men face but don't
always want to talk about think long and
hard you get it 40% of men by age 40
struggled from not being able to get and
maintain an erection well maybe they're
sick of banging the person they're with
why do you always have to blame the dick
I'm sorry why do guys turn to weird
solutions or do nothing when they can
turn instead to medicine and science
expensive pills injection where no man
wants an injection share any experience
you've had with doctors in dealing with
edie issues I fortunately uh the little
little bills still [ __ ] you know he's
still in the game
you know he's a journeyman my Dick's
playing for the league minimum but he's
still in the league he's getting a
pension check out hims and you could
discover the tiny pill worthy of a big
celebration for hims calm a one-stop
shop for hair loss skin care sexual
wellness for men answer questions about
your medical history and check with a
doctor for confidential for a
confidential review if approved by the
doctor products are shipped directly to
your door being your best means
performing your best its erectile
without the dysfunction this is going to
be the hottest year of your life try
hims today by starting out with a free
online visit go to four hymns calm / /
Edie that's fo r hims calm / birbee you
are our capital e d for hymns calm /
borough e d prescription products are
subject to doctor approval and require
online consultation with the physician
who will determine if a prescription is
appropriate see website for full details
and safety information this could cost
hundreds if you went in person to the
doctor's office or pharmacist
remember that for hims dot-com / / oh
that's for hims com / / edy all right
all right I have a very exciting
announcement here let me make sure I get
to the right email so last year old
freckles went to New York City the big
city skyscrapers and everything hey wait
I didn't know it's my favorite acting
ever that's Stevie Stevie Ray Vaughan
and that Stevie Wonder song hey wait I
didn't know
alright king of Staten Island alright
Universal will announce the king of
Staten Island release on Monday April
27th at around 12 p.m. Pacific time 3
p.m. East Coast judge will post a video
that's the great Judd Apatow will post a
video that he made with Pete that's the
great Pete Davidson along with
universals one-sheet to his socials
which will also be pushed out by
Universal socials and a press blat blast
Universal asks of you please share on
your social let me know if you have any
questions alright so I will be posting
something at 12 noon pacific time
specific time today that will show i
think a trailer and will let you know
when the movies coming out they're
getting creative with how you can see it
because of the cove it 19 alright guys
I'm not glad this is a big one for me I
even need piston fans on this one if you
guys could watch this movie and help it
to be successful then you know what I
could actually you know maybe you know
get to grow another fake mustache and be
in a movie which could be fun right
watch it if you want to I hope you want
to watch it I think it's a really really
really funny movie and it's got a lot of
hat you know typical Judd Apatow funny
and has some heart and
I saw a cut of it and I thought it was
great and I know they've done a bunch of
other cuts since then so I'm really
excited about this thing alright so I
will let you know 12:00 noon today today
today today all right April 29th yo sup
need to know if Windsor Ontario is
cancelled April 29th I can't get any
answers from the vendor yeah it's
cancelled yeah it's it's [ __ ] it's
beyond cancel do you think that if I
didn't have that [ __ ] gig I wouldn't
be talking about you know every five say
I know I don't know other comedians
doing road gigs but we're gonna take a
chance in Windsor Ontario yeah that's
definitely that's cancelled all right
swiffer bill its Swiffer not swifter you
redheaded [ __ ] jesus [ __ ] christ love
you bill and thanks for the podcast no I
didn't know you know you're like like
three people were really [ __ ] annoyed
that I was saying Swifter I thought you
know but Swift you clean up real quick
it's Swiffer all right well you know
their price gouging the Swiffer I don't
care for its swift or Swift
I'm not [ __ ] buying it so those
prices come down I don't know why I
premiss pronounce so many different
things I just I mean it's my hearing bed
or is it what I don't want to admit that
maybe I'm just not that bright a guy all
right painters hey Billy Burke house key
I'm a union iron worker for the last
weeks I've been building stairs and
handrails for a large manufacturer oh my
god this picture is hilarious
manufacturing facility not to toot my
own horn but I've been told I'm
essential anyway we finished fabricating
and installing the stairs catwalks in
and rails a couple days later the
shit-ass painters show up to paint the
handrail rails safety yellow they ran
through it like Ray Charles on meth when
it comes to the trades they are
definitely the blue-collar bottom of the
barrel I've attached a simple photo of
the pride they take in their work oh
dude would you look at this photo which
I have definitely got a [ __ ] post I
got to post this thing right now to my
Twitter account because I always say I'm
gonna push it and I never [ __ ] do
probably because I just clicked it over
and I just [ __ ] clicked it over I just
tried to drag it over to my [ __ ]
desktop and where is it where is it it
won't let me [ __ ] do it of course it
won't you [ __ ] [ __ ] god damn
[ __ ] I swear to god these [ __ ]
things just don't work for me built
that's such a stupid statement you don't
know how to use computers there it is
that's the reality I'm [ __ ] texting
goddamn Andrew thumbless right [ __ ]
now to post this [ __ ] photo that he's
gonna post in two seconds the [ __ ] is it
come on come on come on here we go here
we go
all right Andrew please post that
picture of the bad paint job on my
Twitter immediately all right so if you
look at this [ __ ] photo it looks like
somebody is pouring yellow paint down
onto these stairs the way he took this
picture it's a they painted like though
the the part of the railing the banister
has old people call it where it meets
the stairs it's just like it's like they
just dumped the paint down it oh my god
I love that I love it people please send
me more pictures of painters not having
pride in their job all right oh my god
that's [ __ ] fantastic hey painters
hey Billy the Baldy [ __ ] who used to be
a ginger [ __ ]
you're always on about cheap [ __ ] but
maybe you were a cheap [ __ ] when you
hired the [ __ ] blind drunk painter
you [ __ ] I'm a pain in myself and can't
wait to hear all the emails you get
about it what's the over-under on how
many people say they hope you die in a
plane crash
you're [ __ ] Kennedy wannabe all the
best you [ __ ] yeah you really didn't
defend yourself sir like I mean I'm
talking every house I've ever moved into
Oh all right lived in I've only moved
into one that I've been able to afford
but all the houses my parents had every
[ __ ] one of the paint jobs they just
suck okay it's not like you walked in on
the guy who hung the door it's only on
one hinge he still hangs the door listen
listen the same way as a comedian I know
why that went as much as people respect
stand-up comedy I know why that whenever
they show a comedian or somebody's
playing a comedian they're on offstage
have a lampshade on their head and are
[ __ ] annoying to be around I
understand why that stereotype exists
all right so don't don't be a precious
[ __ ] all right let take an honest look
at some of the work like finding a
really good painter I mean if you have
any suggestions in LA please let me know
or submit let me know if you're a
top-level [ __ ] painter that's what
the [ __ ] I'm looking for I don't want
someone to go in there like [ __ ]
Helen Keller in a bad mood and just
[ __ ] hey can you paint this closet
and they paint over everything including
like you the [ __ ] window paint the
[ __ ] window shut slant flaps loops
lap close it lock it there you go
all painted including the [ __ ]
hardware yeah I still don't I respect
the art of painting as much as the
people who do it do that's as close as I
will come how's that does is that is
that enough of an olive branch for you
Oh painting is a real job you can't
I'm not saying it isn't it seems like a
[ __ ] of a job and actually I can tell
by your work how hard it is huh because
it seems you guys want to get it over
with this because quickly as possible
all right painting is a real job you
[ __ ]
I don't think I've ever been called it I
think Detroit Pistons fans after today I
will call me a [ __ ] less than painters
dear bill I don't know why you give pain
or such abuse so much abuse because of
the job that they've done because of the
amount of [ __ ] windows that have been
painted shut doorknobs painted
completely over [ __ ] with the [ __ ]
latch meets the lock completely [ __ ]
painted over splotches of paint on
hardwood floors paint on the [ __ ]
windows that's why Jesus Christ it's
like did you paint Oh did you [ __ ]
bust a nut it's it's all over the place
I don't know why you give painters so
much abuse just because you let some
[ __ ] into your house and paint him to
cover your wall with paint doesn't make
them a painter any more than you are a
barber when you shave the red off the
side let's go the man made a good point
there the reason you hire a painter is
so you don't get [ __ ] splashes of
paint on your precious Netflix money oh
you know what this whole [ __ ] thing
will you [ __ ] on [ __ ] you you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I used to wash windows you nan
funny douche go to an open mic and beat
out ten million [ __ ] comics [ __ ] you
I earned every [ __ ] cent of my
Netflix money you window paint and
[ __ ] hack
go [ __ ] yourself and [ __ ] all you people
who [ __ ] on people that make it in show
business you just [ __ ] you're not
happy with your own [ __ ] lives jesus
[ __ ] christ who the [ __ ] are they
hurting slept on a futon until I was 36
years old my precious Netflix money [ __ ]
you I hope you stepping up
gonna pay today you can't alright
everything else was fine I don't mind
you saying that I'm not a painter I
might call me a bald-headed [ __ ] but you
[ __ ] stay out of my pockets I earned
every [ __ ] dime I've made in this
[ __ ] business standing on stage is a
[ __ ] nobody in front of a bunch of
drunk heckling me the whole [ __ ] way
and I took the pain and you know what my
ship came in and go [ __ ] yourself
go [ __ ] yourself I have Netflix money
I'm not giving you a drop of it I hope a
bat comes up and bite you right on your
paint select [ __ ] neck you [ __ ]
alright precious Netflix money but
designer furniture and wine he spelt sat
whi ne on the sari and whined about it
on the internet I saw you were right
there it doesn't take a genius to figure
out that there's people out there
calling themselves painters and they do
it just just as bad a job as you would
do if you do it no this is what amazes
me sir is every apartment everything
I've ever [ __ ] been in the windows
have painted shut all these all this
great old hardware every place I've
lived in has been old as [ __ ] and people
just painted over all of it and this
paint all over the [ __ ] floor I'm
just saying look just where are these
[ __ ] great painters all right in
defense of you though if I walk into a
really nice governmental building
there's not [ __ ] paint all over the
[ __ ] floor I don't know I'm just
saying that there's a lot bit listen
listen there's a lot of bad painters out
there I would actually say there's more
bad painters out there than there's bad
comedians okay because being a bad
comedian you at least have to have a set
of balls to get on stage alright anybody
can put on their white on white Jam jams
and go walk in and start coloring on the
walls like you sir [ __ ] you the gloves
are off buddy you went after my few you
[ __ ] went after the money iron
designer furniture what does that look
like does it have the Jordache jeans
Inge on the back
stupid [ __ ] let me tell you something
about designer furniture you can take
that [ __ ]
turn it up sideways as the rock says and
shove it straight up you [ __ ] candy
ass
I hate all that designer [ __ ] I hate
designer
I don't like designer clothes I bought a
couple of expensive suits when I had the
[ __ ] do Letterman and all that the
biggest nightmare ever ever was wearing
expensive clothes ever anything you
brush up against Oh living in New York
City getting in filthy [ __ ] cabs
stupid why somebody would buy a designer
couch why would you do that so you can
[ __ ] lay there and fall asleep and
drool on it I don't understand any of
that all right sir so I know you think
that I'm just sitting here rolling
around in a pile of [ __ ] money you
know with like I don't know what my name
engraved with an oil painting of myself
like I'm in [ __ ] MTV Cribs I'm not
I'm not okay so go [ __ ] yourself okay
and I know that your little butt hurt
here okay why don't you take the
paintbrush out of your [ __ ] ass you
baby and you know take a little
criticism anyways
all right it doesn't take a genius
actually agree with a lot of his points
you know what it really is is shut the
[ __ ] up about the fact that I actually
took a chance and my dream came true
go [ __ ] yourself and [ __ ] all you
[ __ ] people who keep [ __ ] on
celebrities in their big-ass [ __ ]
kitchens they earned them all right do
you have the balls to stand across the
table from a naked Harvey Weinstein
that's in heat do you want to [ __ ] do
that do you if you could step into that
ring with that ugly orange orangutan
coming at you let the [ __ ] hard-on if
you can handle that [ __ ] oh I'm a
painter let's all cry for the painters
go [ __ ] yourself and your stupid van it
doesn't take a genius to figure out that
there's people out there will calling
themselves painters and they do just as
bad as you care you read that and sure
it's not rocket science to apply a coat
of paint but paint selection is often
overlooked by amateurs see this is what
I like the
the at of it it's one thing to slap some
blue paint on your dirty looking white
walls okay here's here's an argument on
his side how do I know that the paint
isn't from the last person that rented
the apartment what it really is is it's
probably from the cheap landlord that's
what it is then I got damn and he's
gonna [ __ ] convince me that I'm wrong
I'm not wrong about you talking about my
money you [ __ ] [ __ ] but maybe I
deserved that because I went after your
trade I don't know yeah you're probably
[ __ ] right all right you're right all
right it's one thing to slap some blue
paint paint selection but it's one thing
to slap some blue paint on your dirty
looking white wall it's something else
to first carefully clean and patch the
wall tape off sections for protection
apply a good coat of water-based paint
primer nobody does that
then proudly take control of your roller
proudly and your container of glossy
aquamarine oil paint and turn the room
into something into someone's happy
place I work quick effectively and take
pride in my work I really piss this guy
up people often can't thank me enough
for the job that I do oh [ __ ]
I was with you till then so keep on
paying some bum eight bucks an hour to
paint your wall
I hope the reason why it looks like [ __ ]
will eventually penetrate your head
stupid redhead keep doing what you do
with love and disrespect all right
you're right you're right listen to what
he said there I think what it is is is
so much of my life I rented and you know
landlords are notoriously cheap so they
probably just hired a bunch of [ __ ]
college kids people move out they fix
the wood and then they just slap white
paint you know why you know what you're
right you're right and then I bought the
house and my house was a hundred years
old and a bunch of tight [ __ ] or
do-it-yourselfers probably painted it
and I blame
your trade you know what Touche sir
you're absolutely right but you know
what god bless you for writing that
[ __ ] email because it was funny as
hell and it also took up a good ten
minutes of the podcast there all right
all right I'm done [ __ ] on painters
he's right but you know what I needed to
do it to learn something and you know
what he was right you see this I hope I
say a Thomas is listening to this
economy dear Billy blind faith
remember when anyone who questioned
bombing Iraq after 9/11 was given the
business uh yeah I do remember that
because I was one of those guys going
why are we going after Iraq the Dixie
Chicks and all of that yeah I do
remember that I bring that up routinely
on this podcast well well it seems like
that now about well it seems like that
now about restarting the economy and
we're going to look back at how [ __ ]
up it was if we go past the first week
or two of May so many people will lose
their businesses I don't think it's
being talked about enough because of the
stigma dude like I don't even know what
your point was there yeah I am honestly
I am I definitely think that they need
to reopen the economy because of that my
analogy has been you can't make 60% of
the people homeless because you know I
don't know [ __ ] less than 1% has Co
vid 19 you know at some point we have to
let people go back to work people have
to earn a living people have to be able
to pay their mortgages and I do not want
to see a bunch of mom-and-pop places go
out of business
and that these corporations are able to
ride it out and we get even less less
options to go to places like that and I
don't know what worries me is
politicians are in the pockets of
corporations and I know how corporations
think as all people do and all they care
about is money and they might look at
this covet 19 thing as an advantage a
way to get rid of you know what's left
of their competition like explain to me
why grocery stores are open but farmers
markets aren't like why can't farmers
markets come up with like okay well you
just stand over here six feet apart
we'll let certain amount of groups and
this is the way you walk through the
farmer's market why can't you do that
maybe you can't I mean I haven't
investigated but I don't think you can
and I would think well that you know
that's that's great for grocery stores
yeah it's a very i that's I I don't want
to see that okay that's like we've
already had enough sadness with all
these old people people's grandparents
dying in these old folks homes and all
that type of stuff I I don't want to see
a bunch of people who had a dream to
start their business and you know that
goes away and then everybody has to work
for [ __ ] Amazon I don't want to see
that like anybody else so I'm hoping
that they open they they should open it
back up I think that they should younger
healthy people are able to fight this
things off it seems as long as you don't
have a respiratory problem whatever
granted I don't have a medical
background but just what I've been
hearing so I think they should be
allowed to go to work and if you're in
the prime of your life I don't think you
should lose your business and if you're
a young married couple and you just
bought a [ __ ] house I don't think
that you should lose your [ __ ] house
and your credit should be ruined and all
of that type of [ __ ] so I think we
really need to be looking at that too
and there is a test for it and if we can
have all of this money to fight these
never-ending Wars I believe we can print
some more [ __ ] money to get everybody
tested and just have the fun just get
everybody [ __ ] tested that you
possibly can every job that's out there
right if you know if you're gonna open
if you're gonna open up your job all
right
you have to get all your workers tested
and everybody gets [ __ ] tested then
they come into work and then you [ __ ]
fight but then it's like what do they do
have to work
with a [ __ ] where they going Bubba
this is what you do you know you know
those stupid things
I voted the stickers that people wear
like they're [ __ ] two-year-olds
basically I was tested get those things
right now but then stronger people will
rip them off the chest to somebody else
because they don't want to get tested
and then they'll work you know there's
always gonna be somebody licking fruit
in life you know what I mean
I don't know what to do it's [ __ ]
chaos they should just open it back up
and whoever lives libs whoever dies dies
what the [ __ ] you gonna do we got to
keep marching ahead because this is the
world that we live in and hopefully in a
year they'll have a [ __ ] vaccination
there you go this is what happens we let
a comedian solve real problems all right
overrated underrated deer build the burg
meeting overrated binging shows oh I'm
with you I'll tell you starting shows I
can't remember the last time I started a
[ __ ] show I just don't want the
[ __ ] you know it's you know I start
thinking about it and then I did should
I need to get done and I don't cuz I'm
gonna go [ __ ] watch it you like you
like you're on heroin but like watching
TV anyways he goes I can use two shows
you are on you are in on the advantages
of weekly shows versus binging shows
look what happened what happened with
the mandalorian each week after an
episode was released the hype went
through the roof for the next week yeah
I always looked at it like you know when
something like the mandalorian or
Breaking Bad look at me self-promoting
here yet to binge watch those shows
that's like you know shotgunning like a
[ __ ] thousand-dollar bottle of wine
and like that was delicious you got any
more wine each week after an episode was
released the hype went through the roof
for next week and the people had time to
analyze each episode each week and talk
about the workings of the show and this
goes on until the show ends and then
people are still discussing it when a
show comes out all at once people watch
it in a day and it's discussed for a
week or two at the most and then
forgotten yeah
and people don't analyze each episode
because they watch it in
and basically forget about 40% of what
they saw
i 100% agree with this people are used
used to instant gratification and it
sucks children complain when shows are
weekly and I wonder how they would have
survived network television well the
same way we did when there's no option
we didn't know about streaming alright
but if you could have streamed welcome
back Carter back in the day and for some
reason when one-day-at-a-time came out
you couldn't you would have wined as a
kid too as would have i all right
underrated cliffhangers it keeps you
talking and waiting in anticipation for
next week's episodes that's a child
literal every saturday morning cartoon
ended in a cliffhanger with the bad guy
laughing evilly over the good guy I
thought cartoons just sort of ended a
lot of them when Bugs Bunny was
standalone you mean Batman and Robin
Batman that the TV show anyway this is
my anyways as he says this is my opinion
as I say anyways this is my opinion feel
free to disagree go Bruins and Pat's I I
definitely agree with binging but I
don't think cartoons ended with
cliffhangers I don't know my favorite
cartoon of all time I will tell you
though is Jonny Quest oh man as far as
like people they got shot and they died
I just saw him it's just [ __ ]
incredible that original one it's just I
can't say enough good things about it
like if you could buy that box set I
would buy it because I still have a tea
I have a DVD VCR player but it's not
compatible with my [ __ ] TV so I'm
still trying to figure out what [ __ ]
apparatus I need who gives a [ __ ] bill
alright uh alright I just wanted to say
okay music I just want to give you some
suggestions of bands since you were
asking I listened to pretty much
anything that sounds good to me but
mainly a metalhead
check out if you haven't already Opeth
and porcupine tree gate great musicians
and songwriter ena I've dabbled and I
never heard
Opeth ope th I'll definitely check them
out alright to check out Tom mish and
Yusef Dave's new album I somebody told
me about Yusef guy I got a couple of his
albums I think he's [ __ ] amazing
amazing drummer they have a new album
called what kind of music just came out
on Friday you mentioned Yusef days once
before when someone wrote in with the
video recommendation this has full songs
not just drum work oh well guess what
I'm doing right now I'm going to iTunes
to do yet the der that store alright
Yusef days what's the name of the
[ __ ] thing what kind of music what
kind of music bang 999 I'm taking $9.99
of my Netflix money you [ __ ] tacky
you know I hope you I hope your
paintwork isn't as tacky as your [ __ ]
email kind of a man brings up another
man's what the [ __ ] money myself mate
you [ __ ]
oh you go do six shows in the basement
of a [ __ ] spaghetti Freddy's on a
[ __ ] rue one you [ __ ]
sorry I'm really getting tired of that
by the way just hating somebody because
they [ __ ] went after a dream go [ __ ]
yourself
alright what the [ __ ] is my password did
the underrated having the same password
for everything that I thought it did it
did it D god this is a long password cuz
they kept telling me it wasn't it wasn't
good enough you know [ __ ] [ __ ]
still like my parents no matter what I
do it's not good enough kidding uh I
wasn't really the wrong [ __ ] password
do you think somebody's trying to steal
my [ __ ] account you [ __ ]
and we can do it we can do it bang-bang
bought purchased listening to it thank
you then Opeth I have to [ __ ] figure
out what the hell that is alright that's
the podcast everybody alright god bless
everybody even the bad boy Pistons
except for Isiah Thomas and Bill
Laimbeer everybody else some [ __ ]
cool with me no matter what the [ __ ] I
say one of my favorite [ __ ] teams
ever that early 2000 Detroit piston
teams that that beat the Los Angeles
Lakers and ended their reign that was an
incredible incredible [ __ ] series man
the five five game sweep there I love
that piston team see they go I'm not a
[ __ ] alright I said the rambha's play
was [ __ ] dirty alright there you go
go [ __ ] yourselves yeah on Thursday and
look this noon this noon today noon how
do I promote this today at noon pacific
time if it isn't already just go to my
all my social medias and i will have
hopefully i'll post it a trailer and a
lincoln all that [ __ ] that will let you
know when the king of Staten Island
starring Pete Davidson and Marisa Tomei
directed by Judd Apatow Steve Buscemi
Dom Lombardo Z too many great people to
[ __ ] list
i bleep posting that today 12 noon
pacific time specifically alright that's
it go [ __ ] yourselves and I'll check in
on you on Tuesday
on Thursday that's it Thursday yeah
Thursday